[Music]
you played yourself news
Beto's submitted by poop pyramid there
it is like anime poop when it swirls
into a perfect that's put in a pyramid
form if you tell it's like rabbit
pellets that means you're dehydrated I
would know I'm always dehydrated so it's
always pellets it's always pellet drink
some water drink some [ __ ] water why
do you refuse to replenish your salt
just what your pee looks like they
really have too much down I've been
actually really good because you know
how like I stream like five days a week
every stream they're always yelling at
me to drink water and he reminds me so
that's been really good
thanks guys something you got reminded
by JK news ever since that video came
out like it's been pretty crazy people
will be making sure that I had you
that's good
tweet her left or no water is good for
you we've been trying to get Steve to
drink water impossible I think the whole
three-day weekend yeah I think you drink
probably half the body we saw we drink
Oh a bottle yeah one bottle maybe that
man is the most stubborn man on earth
you will not get him to do anything he
does not want to do but it works in the
positive n negative way one it kills him
he is also a great writer you know Gigi
Hadid is being sued for posting
copyrighted images of herself on
Instagram
wait copyrighted images of herself that
says I can't tell which ones which
honeyed by the way I don't know who -
Gigi's the younger one and then fella is
the older one
darker hair she's with the weekend are
you this is Gigi wait is that the one
with the weekend no no her sister no she
has a hella long way the one that got
into a fight or slap someone I remember
we did like something we're like someone
I think it was one okay yeah actually
getting hell up in her face and she was
like my mom she's Chinese
I don't think yeah you report you help
deliver the nothing he was back when
Julia was real it was you that capoeira
is and they did issue is she wasn't
supposed to release the photos yet
before the brand does know so apparently
this is a common thing in Hollywood damn
her as long as our [ __ ] pourcel to a
head at the heels it could be really
long I mean she's tall a lot of
celebrities are getting sued by
photographers because these celebrities
are posting photos that the
photographers have been taking that
their copyrighted images who owns it
like guess owns it
the photographer photographer for guests
owns it haha they are usually taken by
paparazzi and they copyright Oh
paparazzi are like the scum of the earth
exactly so then now they're not making
money by selling photos of celebrities
as much as they used to in the past and
countersue right because the pop rocks
taking pictures without even best their
face yeah they're not even agreeing to
it laws for that paparazzi laws republic
yeah yeah and so freeing stuff so
because of copyright laws they can't
legally use these photos of themselves
without asking for permission that make
sense without crediting can i copyright
my face and then i license this and then
they take a picture of my license and
then i sue them for using my license
product yeah cuz that doesn't make sense
to because i know like people who are
like that's my celebrities are
considered an entity in and of itself
it's a brand so if you're using their
face for the your profit can't they
counter sue them saying like you can't i
think it was if they were taken in
public because it's not illegal to
record or take pictures in public so
that means you know they can take
pictures of you and then they win the
copyright under their name so if you
want to use that photo from that
photographer you have to hit them up
first your own likely yes if you don't
give them credit or if you don't ask for
permission and that's when they sue you
and that's my stuff
Jennifer Lopez $0.50 Jessica Simpson
Khloe Kardashian they've all been sued
for posting photos of them and I love
them just walking to some cool walking
down the street so because of this now
celebrities are hiring their own
photographers work like paparazzi
photographers Oh animal photography
company and color probably to easy I
guarantee you that exists for sure
huffing domain right now it exists
carpets walking carpets are the best
blocking carpets dogs those shaggy dogs
oh I just didn't want the dreadlocks
those are funny make it look like those
those are the Afghani ones already well
stay in one place god damn it I know do
you think you would work if I sued my
blog channel for using my face I mean
you can probably successfully sue it
yeah but you're affecting me I had
nothing to do with that what if I on the
blog days I sue you for filming me you
sue each other for each other's money it
goes backwards not illegal to suit I
mean to filming people in public in
public using my likeness but it is
because you have to get their consent
for filming yes you do yeah for filming
you do commercial filming right yes
that's I'm like I don't know this is
commercial though cuz no even even
commercial field filming you're you're
making money off of it I mean you're
selling these pictures yeah they're
selling it that's why I'm so confused
because even like on YouTube videos if
if you're shooting something and
somebody sees their face on it yeah they
don't like it they could sue you yes
because they didn't find a release form
or sign a release form yep when we do
our show like the send foods show
everybody who is in the video has to
sign a release even if we blow out their
face they stuff to sign everything how
do you get everyone in the background
together yeah you gotta have a good
producer you have to blow out there hey
we used to shoot with simple pickup
there'll be like three or four of
production coordinators with clipboards
and they're just flying after people
constantly any please
I work and I think there's like a
certain amount like let's say they're
just walking by and it's like the side
of their face you're okay
but if it's like I forgot what the what
the thing was but yeah that's I'm so
confused as to how they're able to get
away with it because all those people
who record things like oh yeah you know
cuz those all those racist people yeah
you're not supposed to record me in
public delay goes like no it's it's
legal I think it has to do something
with like maybe advertising or like you
have to publicly state that you're
advertising or whatever some people are
just [ __ ] weird dude cuz Merrill and
I when we went to we do like a little
staycation link in the NAP area for a
wedding thing and I just placed my
camera there there's layers I hope
you're not recording because if you do
you owe me money
I was already irritated because our
flight got the latest [ __ ] I looked at
outside oh are you a celebrity that she
was no there why the [ __ ] would I record
you who are you I remember when I was
getting like an Instagram story where I
was and she this one lady was I excuse
me I don't want to be in your video and
I'm just like I'm not even [ __ ]
getting you what the hell chill you're
not important yeah the [ __ ] lady was
a [ __ ] dude I was like what the [ __ ] I
said cool are you just I just don't want
to be recorded I was like are you are
you somebody special
no then I'm not recording you [ __ ] it's
not even on I'm talking about worried
about that it's so [ __ ] weird and if
I got in trouble because I was being
mean to the lady because Mary got mad at
me Oh have you guys been in a place for
like someone's like secretly recording
it yeah it was creepy as [ __ ] what you
guys do like fans there's like weird
fans I do that sometimes I hate it when
they do the upskirt thing to me did you
know do that where they like record you
from far away just calling out yeah I
was like what are you doing [ __ ]
weirdo
it makes it so uncomfortable I don't
mind taking photos just don't like dude
they think they're being so just free
but they're like yeah you can spot them
immediately yeah if you're gonna do it
just gonna [ __ ] do it
you tell me if you saw celebrity across
the [ __ ] way and then you're watching
a game of [ __ ] you won't do it I'd do it
that's true actually do it as someone
recently opened up like this this
differently oh [ __ ]
Zeppelin diesel that's different than
like alright that's weird that's what I
do I did it recently when I was vlogging
yeah and the celebrity guys behind me
I'm like
my god I can't go to him and say hi who
is it who's that it uh I always forgot
his name what's showing movies young
things levy oh yeah he's a Latino Josh
let me know not Josh [ __ ] the one that
used to be Oh chachi no like actual
big-time means I'm Holly with a huge
celebrity in Latin America oh my god I'm
Pony Oh laddy
how is that his name I don't ever take
photos of celebrity cuz they don't
interest me because I see them
everywhere but if I see a really hairy
funny-looking person I'll take a photo I
think I'm only taking one celebrity
photo in k-town I saw a guy eat a can of
beans and take a [ __ ] through a bench
took a photo William Levy like he was
sitting on you know those blue oh he was
eating the can of beans with a straw and
then he was [ __ ] through the bench
and I took a photo and I laughed but
then I looked at the phones kind of sad
so I deleted it looks like he smells
like a man damn that's a beer that was
bankrolling so bad and I'm KP like just
go up to him all night no no also you do
so will your celebrity people that you
would do that - what the [ __ ] celebrity
are you trying to hug one person I
freaked out over it was a video game
producer I don't think I would like
because I know how it feels like when
you're with your family or you're like
in your own mindset and agenda like I'm
trying to just buy milk or whatever I
know how it feels to get interrupted in
your day so I don't think I would
interrupt any celebrity I would but Dave
Chappelle he's like my idol and I for
him I would be Rick James [ __ ] and you
run away please please please please let
me get a picture with you this wasted so
much of cocaine is a hell of a drug bye
nice and or like let you finish your
[ __ ] first
oh I London I come up to you I [ __ ] I
mean like I'm never gonna say nope and
I'm like there is time so I'm sitting on
the inside of the booth and it's like
hey can I get a photo and then like all
my friends have to scoot out haha I
always say no if I'm eating I've already
and a million [ __ ] times yeah if I'm
eating with somebody it's really awkward
for the person sitting across from me so
it's not for me
like if I'm by myself whatever they
don't give a [ __ ] come over here but I'm
having a meal with somebody and that
person has to watch that whole ordeal go
down right and it's just like I feel bad
yeah I feel like an [ __ ]
but every time without like let's listen
whatever dude
so I'm fine with to the point where my
friends don't even care anymore oh yeah
whatever these continue eating order
also if I'm mid-bite I'm [ __ ] hungry
man all right excuse me I know that
hi I got a question for you guys how do
you guys know if you're friends with
someone
uh-huh cuz I do what we're talking about
no it does cuz I was we were at
something at somewhere
I know his dump and I was there I'm not
sure if dave was there but John Cho is
there let's talk to my John chill for a
little bit so I was like I think we're
friends now yeah and then I was at the
Americana and I saw him walking with a
bunch of dudes come on boy hey yo Johnny
I wanted to say that but I was like I
don't know four friends and you might go
[ __ ] is this weirdo
cause you might not remember who I am I
know what that feels like because I saw
Randall Park right and I love Randall
Park yeah I ran a park was that hey
David big fan of your stuff oh if you
know us your names my [ __ ] names taya
hella happy right yeah saw him too yeah
walking across a caterer didn't say
anything like are we are we cool yeah I
don't want to be that dude light what's
up but he goes yes I'm like just want to
kill myself I don't know it could be
John seemed like it seemed like me and
John were cool but that's also before
his movie you know as when people get
certain things yeah resume ax they're
like more and more into outer space
so before I might've Leia what's up
Johnny hey what's a Barbie can we still
got a birthday party and call it a party
yeah it's a party
it's a party party you're [ __ ] stupid
but it's a party the Parthian we're
seeing at the party but Ramsey says that
Nancy doesn't a great assistant at the
bar day oh yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]